the Joe Rogan experience I just love
guys like him and and and Harlan's what
one of those guys to that their comedies
is very specific to them and like Brody
was a great example that Brody's comedy
is so specific to Brody
like if you see eight one eight to like
die like why is that funny but to you
without you like you immediately got a
smile thinking about Brody saying it cuz
calmly was so specific to him I was a
male model in Pakistan I was on the
cover of camel beet he was so funny we
would ask him to do those jokes - and
he's do the male model joke like you'd
yell out to him Brody did you ever do
any modeling funny ask yeah
Rogan supportive I go Brody how did you
get to the store tonight La Cienega
North took it to San Vicente he would
just say names of roads in LA for five
minutes and it was funny for whatever
reason yeah god I miss that guy he was
like to me it was always like he was
trying to make people laugh and he was
also trying to blow himself up he was
trying to fill himself up yeah he was
like he was doing self affirmations with
this comedy he wasn't boasting he was
trying to convince himself that he was
good enough to be up there forever in my
office I had a photo laminated photo
that said Office Depot employee of the
month
and it was Brody and he took this photo
it was like what he was using as a
headshot it's I kept it just to give you
a smile I was writing I put it up on my
little cork board see if you can find
that man I needed to get another one of
those I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened to it when he died I've never
seen I don't think I've ever seen a
turnout for a comedian dying said it the
way that laminated in my office please
do me a favor and print that up and
let's get it get that turned into
another one that I put in my office cuz
I somewhere in the move from this studio
from the old studio the studio
lost it but I always had that in my
office just to look at just cuz Brodie
was just so Brody yeah he was just open
raw and he you know he was one of those
guys where you really have to be there
you have to see him yeah like it's an
he's he's not he doesn't translate
no one translates 100 that's a dirty
little secret about comedy specials you
don't translate a hundred percent of
what you're experiencing when you're in
that room that's why your writing has to
be even sharper and your your act outs
have to be even sharper everything has
to be tightened down because you're not
experiencing the physical presence of
all the audience members and the
comedian all in this room together
because it's an intangible right so if
like going to see you live at the Wilbur
theater if that's a hundred percent
watching you on Netflix it's like 80
percent yeah the takeaway all the other
people there's no other people there
it's just you you can pretend they're
there but they're not there so you don't
have that feeling of being in a public
place with a bunch of other people which
lights you up and then you don't have
the comic that you came to see right in
front of you you don't have that yeah
you don't have the air you're all
sharing the same air you're all in the
room together you feel each other in
some sort of a weird way so it's like
twenty percent of every show but with
brilliance of the momentum of like if
you cut if you come to a comedy show
you're surrounded by people that have an
agenda to laugh they got a babysitter
they paid money they sat down they are
motivated you laugh and so now you're
surrounded by if you're the Wilbur
theater you have a thousand people that
all have that energy together you're
sitting in your underwear under a
blanket on a couch watching a show yeah
it's it's eighty percent though for the
most part yeah maybe might be in the
seventies seventy-nine